um good afternoon everyone um
in the next hour and a half we're going
to explore
an area which i've been looking at for a
while now for a few years uh to do with
um
semantic text similarity um what i'm
going to do is the
the um
the format of the presentation would be
kind of semi-formal in a way so i'll
kind of walk you through my exploration
of this space
there is some code uh however um
i've just noticed that it's going to be
difficult for you guys to probably you
know run the code interactively as i
kind of embark on the tutorial so i
think and i've sent the all the
information um on the repo you know
where the code is located i think that's
on stark
uh so you guys can have a look at that
code then but what i'll do is i will be
running the code uh during the tutorial
i'm going to spend the first probably
half of the tutorial just kind of
walking you through
you know the things i've found in this
space uh you know my own sort of sort of
research semi research it in the area
and my findings and then towards the end
we'll sort of um i'll kind of run
through
a bunch of demos about three demos
where i will try to
illustrate you know um you know my
findings essentially uh in this area
so i guess without any further ado
the agenda will be as follows so as i
indicated uh we'll start off with a very
quick intro to the space
and then uh i will
sort of explore what is semantic text
similarity and what does it really mean
and then we'll sort of
kind of spend some time looking at how
to
compare
documents uh
actually precisely sentences in this
case so
um anything that's
essentially nothing more than
a maximum of 50
tokens
and then we'll spend some time then
looking at um some some basic nlp
pre-processing steps required
and then uh we'll then kind of dive into
uh some sort of feature engineering
steps that are required
uh
in order to convert text into a form
that allows it to be processed by a
machine essentially embedding
and then
we'll then kind of delve into how you
can visualize
embeddings
you know these vectors how do you
actually you know how how can you
visualize um what is essentially
a high dimensional vector and then sort
of
kind of
reduce it to 2d so you can visualize it
and then
we'll kind of have a look at some of my
demos and then you know
we'll have a q a so that's the
the plan
so
introduction um
i got involved in this space because i
was working on a problem which
which required
a solution for one to be able to compare
cvs against
job specs
and
typically cvs are you know these huge
documents and and
you know just specs as well are kind of
huge documents but they all kind of
both
are composed of sentences so i was
trying to find a way
that can allow me to match
jobs to cvs and that's kind of how i got
involved in this um
as we all know um being able to compare
techs is critical and is actually
growing you know as we all know i mean
nlp that space is just
kind of growing exponentially because a
lot of our data actually is in textual
form
so typical areas where this is kind of
uh of use will be
recommendation systems
um
search engines use a lot of
sentence
um actually involves a lot of semantic
um
text similarity yeah you know for
building a uh search engine and news
aggregators as well kind of use this
technology and then as i said earlier uh
automated recruitment systems again this
is a you know being able to compare um
techs
you know as a precursor to being able to
actually build a recruitment system
and of course uh the folks who do a lot
of work in the
biotechnology space folks who build
sorry folks who build solutions around
drug
um
drug discovery and folks who are looking
at dna structures etc again they do
actually utilize a lot of uh text
similarity
um
computations
and there's a whole bunch of areas that
require this sort of work so it is quite
an interesting space at least i think so
so what is semantics what do we really
mean by semantics so
this slide is just kind of giving you an
insight into
three sentences
two of them
kind of similar one is not so if we just
so first one is saying how are you
and
the guy
on the other end is saying great and
then you've got another sentence which
says how old are you
and of course the answer is i am
20 years old and then you've got the
third sentence which indicates what is
your age so out of those three sentences
which are questions
um if you were to compare the first one
say
say if you were to compare how are you
with
how old are you clearly
when we speak we know that those are two
distinct um
you know sentences
they both have two distinct different
semantic
meaning
and how do you train a machine
you know to be able to do this so that's
really the whole essence of what this
work is all about is being able to give
a machine enough intelligence so that it
can look at text and begin to start to
infer semantics out of text and thus
provide meaning in text
so again this these are just some
definitions i kind of scraped from
wikipedia
so
um you know sds is a solution that
obviously deals with determining
similarity between text as i indicated
earlier
um and
um generally um
i'm
i've kind of narrowed this down just to
sentences phrases
and maybe paragraphs
but not huge documents yeah those
require different kinds of
different kinds of solutions maybe
you know text summarization etc but so
so this is all about just kind of as i
said earlier
sentences which typically have a maximum
of maybe 50 tokens yeah this is where
you typically want to use this kind of
technology
um
and then they've got a uh wikipedia
definition just indicating that uh you
know sts is based on the likeness of
their meaning or semantic content as
opposed to
uh lexicographical sorry lexi
lexicographical
apologies for my pronunciation there um
so so essentially it's not just about
the text or or the structure of the the
text it's really about meaning so in
fact you can have two sentences that
completely have different tokens but
they actually mean the same thing
so it's all about being able to find
semantic meaning in text which actually
is not as easy as as one might think
um
[Music]
as i indicated earlier
this area is
a growing space some of the key players
in this space
you know the usual suspects you know
google microsoft um
[Music]
my
sort of involvement in this um you know
i realized that some of the
latest technologies
that have come to
light have really come from
some of the things that hogging face
have been doing and in fact a lot of the
you know the recent language models are
out there now most of the most powerful
ones are coming from hogging face
and i've you know had a chance to play
with some of these and compare one
against the other
another thing that has been going on for
a number of years in the sort of
research domain has been
uh this whole area called um
um
um it's called um
sem eval where they look at a bunch of
what they call sts benchmark problems so
these are problems which involve
things like
you know a question and answer type
questions where you have a question and
answer
you know
are the questions duplicates or not
again that requires being able to
measure similarity
another one is where they have sentences
or sentence pairs where you're trying to
kind of compare one sentence against the
other are they the same and then the
good thing with that is they also
provide a label so they tell you what
the correct answer really is and then so
then you can build a model and then
compare that model your model against
their findings and then you can then use
that to kind of validate you know if
your model is actually performing
accurately
so as i indicated earlier um
i've got
three demos i'm going to present
um
one the first one we'll just kind of
give you a very brief look at how what
are the metrics one would use to compare
sentences so things like cosine
similarity euclidean
um
distance measure and jacquard you know
similarity then the second demo is where
i've built a very very kind of toy
um
sort of search engine again based on has
a corpus of sentences and and then
here's a query how close is that query
to all the sentences um in the corpus so
you know that's
and then the third one is kind of where
i've done a um i've basically done a
comparative analysis of looking at a
bunch of embedding techniques so from
the very basic
tf idf to the more
kind of contemporary transformer based
models and i've kind of given some
numbers on you know which ones perform
better
so we'll kind of get back to this later
on uh towards the end
so i'm going to start off by just kind
of walking you through
some of the ways to measure
sentence similarity
um
so as i indicated that um prior
they are
a whole bunch of metrics one could use
for measuring sentence similarity in my
work i've just looked at three so i've
looked at jacquard
i've looked at cosine which which is you
know which is quite popular and i've
also looked at um euclidean and then out
of the three i've kind of selected the
one which i think kind of performs the
best
so if we started with jacquard what is
jacquard similarity
jacquard actually when i first
encountered jacquard
i was trying to solve that same problem
yeah so i'm trying to compare
cvs
one cv against a job spec
and i tried out a whole bunch of other
models and i actually then realized
jacquard
and i realized that jacquard
you don't need to encode it per se you
can just take the sentence in its
natural form and tokenize it and then
basically just do a
just compute you know the
um the intersection of all the
you know the sentence
a against sentence b divided by the
union of both sentences and that kind of
gives you a score and that's precisely
what jacquard
similarity is it's a very cheap way to
you know to kind of measure similarity
between tokens but it doesn't
codify
semantics in any way it's it's a
completely mechanical thing
so that's the problem with jackard but
it's it's a good start
and again and here you can see it's
pictorially what's going on so basically
what we're saying here is that we're
looking at the intersection of two sets
and then we're counting how many of
um how many uh items are intersected
divided by the total number of all the
items that are unioned
and that gives you a score
the next one is euclidean which is very
popular in machine learning so you know
we use this a lot to measure all kinds
of use cases where there's distance
uh again one could use this uh metric
uh again in this case you would have a
um two you know the two metrics excuse
me the two
um
the two sentences
and um you know you basically will
you know do a a norm of the two
and that will give you you know a number
um
it usually is very sensitive
to scale
so something to bear in mind that is
very sensitive to scale which is
probably why it's not very popular in
the nlp space but it you know has been
used and can be used you know for
measuring similarity
and then of course the one that's the
most popular way of measuring similarity
is the cosine similarity
metric which again you can see that
mathematically
what's going on is you've got a and b
you know you
you do the dot function of a and b
divided by
you know the norm of a and b and then
basically that gives you a number but
that's between minus one and one and
then you can use that as a metric for
measuring
uh scenarios let me just pause for a
minute on that any questions
okay cool so now
as i said
uh i've got three demos so so so here's
the first one i did which is and i'm
just gonna you know present the findings
but later on i'll actually run you
through my code so here's the first one
so here you can see that we've got a
query
yes simple query it's just uh actually
this is one of the demos called the book
and the book title demo so all it is is
just a list of books that i've got from
some source online
and they just um the data set actually
it's got a lot of other columns but i've
just pulled out
the title
column and in there what i'm doing is
i'm basically saying that if i take one
title i want to compare that one title
to the rest of all the titles in the
corpus and then to see how close is that
one title to the rest so in this case
the query is what you see there hitch
hitchhiker's guide to the galaxy blah
blah
and then i'm basically comparing it
against the rest of all the titles in
the corpus and then obviously
um in the interest of time i'm not
displaying everything so i'm only just
explaining the top 10 i think or top
that's why top 10
in this case and there you can see when
you so the first
two are very close because they're
basically the same thing
and then you can see
how
all the three different metrics how
they've com
you know what their outcome is for each
three of the so for the first two they
all match exactly which is great and
then as you can see there uh as you look
at the third
and the fourth and and so on you can see
that there are variations in how one
will you know in in the outcome of
jacquard versus euclidean versus cosine
yeah so again this is just one way one
could
you know measure similarity any
questions on this one because i know
i've kind of rushed through that a
little bit
yes
correct correct precisely precisely that
exactly
okay any other questions
yes
myself actually use that as a metric but
as i said earlier there are a number of
variant metrics that one could use so
and so i think from what you're saying
there i believe you're saying that that
can somehow fix the scaling issue that
typically is one is what one sees with
the euclidean
is that what you're saying
okay okay yeah yeah yeah true yes yes
yes agreed
agreed
any other questions
okay thank you
okay so we've just touched on
how to measure similarity between texts
next thing we need to do is prior to
actually creating an embedding your text
is made up you know it's come from some
data generation system it's probably
corrupted with all sorts of weird
characters
you know so there's a whole area of nlp
where you need to kind of pre-process
text to make it sort of um you know to
kind of prepare it so that it's it's
actually you know um
in the form where you can truly pull out
information out of
um out of it
so this is where the whole nlp
processing
kind of
step
um
this is where this this is where the nlp
pre-processing step is required
out of the pipeline
so
generally one of the things that one
would need to do is you have your
massive i mean you have your um sentence
first thing you've got to do is tokenize
it you're going to pull out tokens out
of your sentence
okay
you might have some weird characters in
there that have no meaning at all
yeah so and if you leave them in there
they're just going to degrade
you know what you're trying to actually
you know the and the the insights you're
trying to pull out of the text so again
you need to get rid of those guys so
that's what's called normalizing
then um
stop words there's going to be a bunch
of words in there d is you know words
that have
you know they're there but they don't
add anything so you've got to get rid of
all those guys yeah
and then
finally
in some cases um there could be words
that need to be stemmed
or lemmatized yeah and that's because um
say for instance you have run in
yeah you can probably stem that and to
just run you know for instance and again
what that does as well is that that gets
rid of a whole bunch of duplicates
because you might have a lot of these
words which are just adding hardly any
value and they just degrade the sentence
so again you've got to do all these
steps so essentially the next
slide here is just showing you that
whole workflow that's required so you've
got to have a
nlp pre-processing workflow this is
almost
um
a sort of a
given step that one must do you know
when you're trying to
process text
fundamentally different okay
i know what you're doing
is very complex yep
and i think you're right you're right so
i think the way for me to answer that
question politically is to say uh
you've got to
do it in context to the problem that
you're dealing with yeah
but i'm sure you agree with me that
a lot of texts generally
has got a lot of irrelevant characters
or tokens
yeah okay all right thank you
um
any other questions actually uh
yeah thank you
normalization in my i i guess for me
would mean
getting rid of um you know those kind of
um you know those things you get when
you um if you pull
say something from the internet and
you've got those what's that i think you
know and those kind of anchor
tags and all that yeah all that stuff i
don't think they add any real
meaning to you know to the um you know
to to semantics yeah it would just
pollute it so those kind of things you
want to get rid of but again to the
gentleman's point you've got to do it in
context it it really depends on the
domain that you're i mean the problem
domain that you're trying to solve
any other questions
okay thank you
okay now we're moving on to the second
sorry the third sort of step
and this is the most um most interesting
bit really this is now where we're
trying to do feature engineering so
we've got a sentence which is just text
but you want to use a machine to process
a sentence so you can pull out some
semantic meaning so you've got to do
something to that text you've got to
convert into numbers
so
there's a whole kind of history
um
in nlp
you know
which sort of tackles how does one
sort of embed um text
and for such a long time until more
recently you know you know backup words
have you know has dominated that space
for a long time maybe for decades and
has actually you know
has provided a lot of really you know
quite
um
practical solutions
um
so i'm just gonna walk you through that
whole kind of evolution and then how
that got me
sort of to where i am right now where
i've played around with a whole bunch of
other technologies and
and got me to where we are today of
course transformers is the like the new
kid in the block right now and that's
sort of completely revisionized you know
nlp you know it's got nlp to a level now
where image was maybe vision was maybe
10 years ago so you know um but i i'm
just gonna
gonna try to sort of walk you through my
experience um
in this space
so of course you have um bag of words or
sometimes called count vectorization
i've not included that in my analysis
because i
just don't think it's going to add that
much value but i have looked at tf idf
which is a better form which is a one
step ahead of
bag of words
there's also word embedding which 10
years ago was like the best thing ever
in nlp where you have a shallow neural
net and then you can train it to learn
neighboring words or you can train it to
take one word and then
sorry to
to take one word and then tell us the
neighboring words um
and then
you've then had
transformers of course other things
happened between from word embedding to
transformers but i've kind of just
ignored that and you see here this is
just my this is not scientific at all
this is just my own kind of
observation in the space
that this is the evolution of you know
how i see things evolving in time
and performance slash complexity
so we started off with bag of words
which has been around for decades then
you had tf idf tfidf was trying to say
you know not you can't
assume that every single word matters
that some words are more important than
others
and then you had word embedding and then
word embedding there's so many variants
the word embedding
yeah especially
when you're trying to go from word
embedding to sentence embeddings yeah
because they're two different things
there's a lot of things you need to do
and then of course we've now
in this brave world of transformers and
there's different kinds of transformers
are out there and they're doing a great
thing in language i mean in language
models
so let's just explore tf idf so so tf
idf the idea is you have a term
frequency
and you have a and then you wait that
term frequency which is basically a
number of times that word appears
in the document
and then you kind of weight it against
this idf this inverse document frequency
and that's to kind of modulate
the fact that not all words that some
words might be irrelevant and so you're
trying to make sure that you're not
putting too much weight on every single
word treating each word as if they're
the same and that's been great actually
there's still a lot of solutions out
there which just use tf idf and tf idf
is a very cheap way to build an
nlp solution a practical nlp solution
that works out there in production and
we've got some you know my company you
know we use them
and it's been great and in fact some of
my analysis later on
indicates that
um tf idf has still got a role to play
like when you compare it to you know the
performance i'm seeing with some of the
more complex models i mean tfidf has
still got a role to play
then
we kind of moved on to word embedding
and word embedded now i think was a game
changer
so this is the first time where you can
now actually start to see real semantics
in words so so the problem with tf idf
is tfidf still has the problem
of bag of words because tf idf you still
have a very sparse matrix
a sparse matrix
and
and
you know most of that
doesn't really have as much meaning
and secondly the other problem with tf
idf is
um
it doesn't really capture semantics
in any way
when we then evolved to the point where
we now have word embedding word
embedding suddenly actually allowed us
to you know get a shallow neural net
train it and actually train it so that
understands words
um and you know words
in its neighborhood
and that suddenly gave us the power of
semantics especially at a word level
and and i think what i'm saying here is
kind of just walking us through you know
some of the um the benefits of um um you
know word embedding the fact that word
embedded doesn't suffer this problem of
uh sparsity of you know your matrix
because your vocabulary generally is
very very large and it's a very large
um vector
excuse me matrix actually um because
basically it's a number of words in your
vocab vocabulary along this axis and a
number of documents along this axis
sometimes this could be very very large
and most of it's just zero it's just
zeros in there it's fast with uh with
word embedding when you train a neural
net to split out a word embedding you
basically predefine the dimension of the
vector
and that's typically 50 100
200 300. you know it's well defined and
so it's a much smaller
vector
that tries to
um
capture semantics as well yeah um
there are variants
word embedding technologies are out
there
the three most popular ones that we all
know of is uh word to vec from by google
you have um
glove
by
stanford university and then
i think facebook also has something
called fast text
for the work i've done here i've been
using glove
but again you know
words of um i have used word to vec
in the past and i've also you know used
fast text
so what is a word embedding
so here we can see an example where
we've essentially embedded the the word
man woman
uh king and queen
actually this is this has come from a
very kind of classic example for you
know word embedding and there you can
see what we've done here is we've taken
the word and we've we've now formed and
what is a fixed
vector for those words so and
the interesting thing here is that the
vector is very dense it's not a sparse
vector as one would usually have if
you're trying to do this with a bag of
words or tf idf
and then what's interesting is that when
you then take this in this case this 10
dimensional vector and then convert it
you do some dimensionality reduction
into 2d you can see that actually the
word man and woman kind of have a
relationship
very similar to the word queen and king
so so
so clearly
word embeddings
provides us a mechanism to learn
semantics and and i think that's what's
demonstrated here
and then just kind of go into a bit more
what's going on underneath the covers as
i indicated earlier word embeddings are
using shallow neural nets um they're two
typical
um
you could say configurations
oh sorry
columns
oh sorry um so yeah so those are not
actually really columns they're just
simply
um vector
values so in the first case you've got
one two three four five six seven eight
yeah so that's an eight dimensional
vector i
i would say they're trying to um model
um
semantics but in in a kind of spatial
domain
so if you think of
um
so
how do we arrive at this is it's part of
the question you want to answer so maybe
if i show you this so are there two
configurations for creating a word
embedding one is
called continuous bag of words where you
basically say i want to predict
this word because this word is is
surrounded by these other words yeah so
that's called continuous bag of words
okay
so so now you're predicting so
you're basically
getting the machine to understand the
connection between a middle word
and based on its surrounding words
and then you've got this other
configuration which is doing the
converse of that
which is basically saying that here is a
one middle word i want to predict its
neighboring
is neighborhood words so
to answer your question that that vector
is capturing
spatial characteristics of where does
that word fit in what are what are its
neighbor
its neighboring words how is it close to
its neighbors and then it's kind of
providing that
in a sense i mean the outcome is
basically some kind of semantic meaning
right to those words
um so so far we've been talking about
word embedding but actually we want to
solve a problem to do with sentences
so how do we go from a word
that now has
n number of um an n sized vector
to a sentence that maybe has many words
but we want that sentence to have an n
size vector
so
so the most basic way to solve that is
to just do an average so you take each
word that makes up the sentence and then
you simply just take the average of it
so let's say for instance hypothetically
let's say that
the word
we we created um a word embedding of
size 10
and let's say that they're 15 words in
that sentence then you basically just
take an average of all those 15 tokens
and then you end up with a
you know with a final sort of 10 size
vector
and that's the most basic thing to do
now the problem with that though is
it's just an approximation
and actually has some flaws and actually
at times when you do this you realize
that the performance is not so good
and then a whole bunch of other tricks
people have done where they've tried to
uh somehow
um not just blindly just take the
average but they will do something
similar to what you do in tfidf they
will try and weigh
the values yeah based on in fact
one solution uses um the idf portion of
tfidf to sort of weigh the way you will
so you have like a um so you have a
weighted average rather than a normal
average if that makes any sense yeah
the one i found that was very powerful
and i checked this online and i did a
lot of research is this thing here
called sif
and
down the bottom there is the pseudo code
how to
you know how how the sifting works i
mean in a nutshell all it's doing is
it's still taking the vector
um
for each word
but it's then still doing the averaging
so if you look at line number two there
what's going on there is it's taking an
average but this time it's doing a
weighted average and that weighted
average you can see there is
some value a which is some hyper
parameter setting
plus divided by a plus
the probability of the word multiplied
by the vector that's the first bit you
do then
line number
six is the other thing they're doing
where they basically pull in the um
using svd single value
decomposition to pull the first
principal component and then apply and
then essentially
multiplying that so there you can see on
line number six multiplying that by the
vector vs and then they get this value
which is a lot better than just doing a
um
a naive average
of the vectors and actually when i ran
this and and of course this is this is
not new this has been around for a while
you can read it up online um it actually
provides much better results and it's a
very fairly cheap calculation to do it's
not as bad
yeah as going for a more complex
transformer like solution
any questions sorry i i know i've kind
of
rushed through that a little bit yes
okay why is it cause
i can't answer that question um smooth
inverse frequency
um i
i'm guessing here
smooth perhaps because of the averaging
so you're just averaging
but i don't know actually the answer no
no i don't know
yeah probably need to um there is a good
paper so if you read that paper so it's
called a simple but tough to beat
baseline for sentence embeddings yeah
it's a very it's a seminal paper really
really good paper actually it explains
the whole kind of concept behind this
approach
and then some other chap a few years ago
wrote
a library called fse
which tries to
um so he tries to tune the perform
because trying to solve the pca sorry
the svd bit of the problem is very
expensive if you try and do it natively
so so so he used python and a whole
bunch of things to kind of speed up that
process so if you lose his his life we
should which is what i did f um the
library is called fse
uh it's quite it's quite fast right to
compute this
and what he's done is he's basically
extended jensen um jensim which is the
library for doing nlp you know for you
know for doing word embedding he's
extending that library so that you can
also do sentence embedding with it as
well
yeah
does it answer your question sorry
well
maybe not
and um
you know here's the sentence embedding
basically this is just an example of
what it looks like typically it will be
you know of size 300 depending upon so
it all depends on the baseline embedding
you're using so in my case i'm i'm using
glove and i was using a glove um i think
it's glove
300.
again they have all these numbers just
to indicate the size of the vector for
each word so i'm using a glove word
embedding
and then i've then
transformed that word embedding into a
sentence embedding and of course it's
gone through this whole
process of sif which spits out
almost like a resultant vector for the
whole sentence rather than the
individual
vectors of the words in the sentence
does that make sense
yeah okay cool
okay
so so far we've talked about
um
word embedding solutions so we started
off talking about the more rudimentary
tfidf which as i said it's still been
used
in many many solutions and it still has
a place then we talked about word
embeddings and
variant word embedding solutions now
we're going to move on to the the brave
new world of transformers and i'm going
to talk about two
well-known quite popular technologies
now one of them is by google it's called
use which stands for universal sentence
encoder
very very it's a very very powerful tool
um and actually quite fast
um once you've downloaded the
you know the
language model it's really fast um and
really what user's doing is basically in
the black box it's just saying
you give it a bunch of sentences and it
spits out
you know the vectors
yeah the embeddings that's what it's
doing pretty much what i've shown here
and
how does it work so google have
um four or maybe even five now five
versions of use and i think they've kind
of progressed in time so i think
the versions are based on the
um primarily based on the architecture
of the neural nets they use it so i
think google are using two variant
architectures
one is
a transformer
based
architecture which is what's shown here
so i'm not going to go into too much
detail but basically that's just it's
shown there pictorially
and then the other one is based on a a
different architecture which is a
deep averaging network architecture
which is what's depicted here
yep
again if you want to know more about
this please feel free um if you go onto
the tensorflow website they've got some
really cool
um tutorials there on how to on the
inner workings of these and there's also
paper which i think is a very famous
paper that google wrote
on this
this came out in 2018 i think
and then here i'm just showing you some
of the library details you know how you
can run it so just a few lines of code
uh yeah you just import tensorflow you
import tensorflow hub tensorflow hob is
where
is the repository of the actual
model language model and then you just
call that
and and here i'm calling um you can see
that i'm calling version four
and then you just simply call an embed
you just you have a wrapper method embed
and then that just calls it yeah and
then essentially you can then just run
it yeah by saying embed give it the
sentence and and then it spits out
um
a vector a tensor basically splits out a
tensor
okay
then the other
um
transformer based solution that i looked
at
is this thing
called
the group is called sbirt.net
but
their library is called sentence
transformers
actually it's a really really good
solution and what they do is they
they're leveraging hogging faces um
models basically yeah so they've just
written a whole bunch of infrastructure
around hogging face making it a lot
easier to use hog and face sorry guys
apologies and do you all know what
hogging face is i mean i'll give faces
like the big guys right now who are
doing all the nlp stuff yeah they've got
some cool cool libraries making it very
easy for us to do nlp
so um
they use a different
uh architecture uh
known as the siamese
twins
architecture which is shown here i guess
it's time is for obvious reasons so you
have two legs one is for one sentence
there's another sentence
it goes through a burped transformer
model
that embeds it and then it then goes
into a layer with a cosine similarity
layer and then that spits out and then
that predicts or you know kind of trains
the model to tell you if if the words
are similar not similar and then you
measure similarity as a cosine metric
between minus one and plus one yeah
that's kind of how it works this is very
good my only experience is
it it gives you the better i think out
of my
when i did my analysis uh it um this
model had
a better performance
just in terms of
when you compare
um
you know the uh the outcome with respect
to a benchmark problem this had a better
uh performance even much better than
google's
usb
but
my findings with that is slightly slower
than the google's solution so you've
probably got to find a
trade-off between performance and speed
and again this is the api that's how you
would use it so again
but
it's very very simple to use right they
stripped out a lot of the complexity so
just a few lines of code uh so you
basically import
um sorry not import i mean are you yeah
import the library sentence transformers
and then you then also you then
call
the hog in face library that you want to
use so in this case we're using a mini
lm
okay and then pretty much again you just
say model.encode and and it spits out
numbers
okay
i'll just pause there for me because i
think i've rushed this a little bit so
any questions
about
yes
vectors so i understand that
the
word provides
vectors
correct
okay let me try to understand the
question so
first of all do you agree that
bag of words and even tf idf
uh you know what it spits out is an
embedding that is very sparse i mean if
you look at it if you have ever opened
it up for a real problem not a toy
problem
there's a lot of knots inside the
matrix yeah a lot of it just got yeah it
adds no value
so inherently you know that's not going
to give you a very good performance yeah
agreed okay now word embeddings
provide a dense
vector for each word yeah they're dense
i mean that you will predefine it you
know when you train the model you know
the shallow model right to spit out the
word embedding and typically you you
know set it to 100 or maybe 200 or 300.
typically it's 300 of
or maybe sometimes 500 yeah is the
number of um is the um is the length of
the vector so
so inherently that's very dense
okay and
actually when you do the evaluations you
run
sample problems you see that you know
word embeddings generally perform better
than
um
than bag of words or tf idf
are you now i i'm not sure if your
question was that when you now compare
word embedding solutions with
the transformer solution are you saying
that
that um sorry i was trying to understand
that question yeah
correct um
ah okay okay i see um
i would say in general again i'm
generalizing it transformers definitely
outperform everything else in general
that's my observation yeah transform
yeah um transformers so so if you're
looking at cbert or you're looking at uh
use which is the google one those always
are um those will always outperform
other solutions yeah generally yeah and
then word embedding as i said in my um
when i described the solution word
embedding is almost like an
approximation because remember it's a
word embedding so those embeddings those
those vectors only apply to words so you
then have to somehow figure out how to
you know utilize it in the context of
sentences and that's partly why we
average it so averaging gives you a
slightly better result and then the
variance of how you average it maybe you
do a weighted average and then one of
those is the sif you know the smooth
inverse frequency that gives you a
slightly better
actually a much better solution than
just averaging but definitely if you
compare word embeddings to transformers
i think transformers definitely
outperform what embeddings in general
but it's always a trade-off so you know
if you're building a production system
like most of us probably do uh sometimes
you haven't got the
i mean are you gonna do a cost
stroke benefit analysis i mean if it's
gonna cost you x amount
uh in terms of compute
to use a transformer model maybe you're
doing this on the cloud and it costs you
x amount to you know buy that compute
it might be better even though it might
give you
perhaps not
um not a
um perhaps
the performance might not be as good as
a transformer model but it might be
cheaper and much more cost effective to
go for
a sub-optimal model but that's quicker
so these are the kind of kind of cost
stroke benefits analysis that one has to
make in fact i i had one case where i
was using a transformer model but and
this was on azure and it was just taking
too long and it was very expensive and i
resorted back to tfidf tfidf was much
quicker it was cheaper
and
so and even though the you know the
results were not as good as a
transformer model it was a lot quicker
to run
not and so i'm not sure if that answers
your question sorry
okay cool any other questions
okay
all right so i guess the next thing we
want to do now is
now that we've established that we can
build
embeddings for sentences
and these embeddings are dense vectors
we still want to
somehow visualize we want to see
you know
put some kind of understand
what these vectors really mean perhaps
in um in a kind of spatial domain
and typically you know for us humans
that would be two-dimensional or maybe
3d so really the next
bunch of slides is going to go into how
can you visualize these embeddings
yeah
so um
what i've done is i've looked at
providing like a scatter plot so we can
see the embedded in 2d i've also
provided them
another plot like a heat map plot so
that we can actually also look at
once you've got these embeddings and
then you use them to compute
similarity maybe you can produce a
similarity matrix and then you can also
then look at that as a heat map so you
know these are kind of things i've done
to kind of analyze
my results
and then with respect to the embeddings
obviously they are
n-dimensional in size
but we need them to be in 2d so
obviously we need to come up with
mechanisms that allows us to reduce
the dimensionality of the problem into
2d space and of course you would start
to look into some of the classical ways
of doing this so one classical way is
you know
you know
pca
principal component analysis which is a
well-known thing i mean again psychic
learner's got everything in there so so
i've used
pca i've used um
multi-dimensional scaling mds i've also
used um another popular one is t
sne
you know t distributed um nearest
stochastic embedding
and then of course there's another one i
also saw which is this umap thing so i'm
just going to kind of quickly walk you
through what those are
so again all of these libraries are out
there it's all freely available the
first
the first four
sorry the first three are in psychic
learn
and then you map you can just do a pip
install
and you get umap but these i tried all
these for and just to see how and they
do have some subtle differences yeah but
they tell you different things but
they're generally all good
pca obviously is linear
so pca is probably the weakest out of
all four
so um here's a
schematic
uh depiction of
the tf of a tf idf embedding this was
for a problem that i described earlier
the um the book title problem so this is
me just simply you know looking at you
know and embedding
sorry embeddings of the of of the corpus
so basically in here the numbers relate
to the
sentence id
and there you can see that
documents which are similar all
congregate in one cluster and those
obviously you know those which are not
similar in different clusters and this
is how you would typically
you know
if you do pca on
on the
um
on the embeddings this is what you see
using pca
and
by contrast this is me now using um
uh t
sne
as my dimensionality reduction technique
but now i'm using sif sif is the thing i
described earlier which is the word
embedding thing
which and there you can see that's a
subtle difference in the way it's it's
sort of um
a spatial representation of
the
embedded sentence vector
and again just for completeness this is
um
again this is the use
used was the google solution universal
sentence encoder and here i'm using mds
the reason why i'm doing it this way
because i can't you know i can't print
out every single use case because
there's a lot of different combinations
i'm just printing out you know some odd
ones but there you can see that they all
tell you some i mean each use case is
telling you something but it's just that
the way it things especially represented
would be different because because
because the dimensionality reduction
techniques
are slightly different yeah but they
kind of still provide you
insights you can see that their
clustering
of of documents
and that tells you that those documents
are going to be
the ones that are very similar to each
other
and this is expert so again here the
embedding
approach is using the expert transformer
model
and here i'm using the umap
sort of two-dimensionality
sorry and the umap
dimensionality dimensionality reduction
technique
okay
next bunch of slides ah sorry yes
correct
no it's a good question it's a good
question uh did i do
i
anecdotally i think i did by just
looking at the
looking at the you know the um the
visuals
but if you're saying did i quantify any
differences no i didn't however what i
i'm going to show you towards the end is
i did quantify the differences between
the five different embedding techniques
and i will give you those numbers
towards the end yes
yes
okay
okay okay okay so uh it's a good
question um so in this context i was
only reducing dimension um the dimension
purely
um to explore
spatially
the representation of the vector it
wasn't because i was trying to do
clustering or or this sort of thing no
no it was probably for me just to kind
of um just to study the spatial
representation of the vector
so i'm not sure if your question is that
um which model
would you use for embedding because
there are two kind of decisions there
one first decision is how do you embed
your data do you want to embed it using
any of the five approaches from the
simple tf idf to the more complex expert
you've got to make a decision and that
decision also is also predicated on
uh computing costs yeah okay and then
second decision is depending upon your
problem what what problem what problem
are you trying to solve if you're trying
to simply solve the problem of trying to
measure similarity between sentences
then really you don't need to do any
dimensionality reduction i did it
because i was trying to understand
the spatial representation of the
vectors but
but if your problem does require you to
do some kind of clustering and you want
to take a very massive you know
dimension
vector and turn it into something
smaller to enable you to do clustering
then yes uh my advice would be
i would say maybe t
s and e is a more popular one that
people tend to use these days yeah
but that's just my
i think again
um to the gentleman's problem i have a
question earlier it's subjective to the
domain and probably you're trying to
solve yeah
yes please
ah okay good question good question yeah
yeah sorry um so i know i started off by
talking about
similarity
metrics
euclidean cosine and um jacquard yes
after doing that i kind of just
decided on using cosine anyway cosine is
the most popular way of measuring
you know um
sentence similarities so yes cosine
any other questions
okay so
sorry
um answer your question i try to answer
your question at least
oh sorry um and
the gentleman and did i answer your
question or
okay thank you all right so i guess the
next thing now is we've just looked at a
scatter plot just to see how what
happens when you
kind of compress from you know from an n
dimension to two
the next thing we're going to do now is
we're going to take the similarity
measures that we've just done but this
time we're going to do it as a
as a matrix
but i cheated a little bit so rather
than do the whole matrix so so typically
let's say you have a a corpus
hypothetically a corpus of 10 documents
10 sentences
then typically your similarity will be
10 by 10
same as you have 100 points
but actually
because
it's a symmetric matrix you don't need
to do all 10. you only need to do half
yeah because number one you don't need
to do
document one against document one you
don't need to do that because it's gonna
be one we know it's gonna yeah if you
compare itself by itself it's gonna be
one then secondly let's say you have
document id one document id two document
the similarity between document id one
and document id2 is a value a equally
that value a is also the same as the
similarity between two against one so
that's why if you look at this matrix
here the half of it is completely black
because it is blank because it's
essentially a cross
value of the other does that make sense
so it's just a way to save time and you
know compute
so i'm going to walk you just very
quickly just walk you through some of
the findings again anecdotal i haven't
measured anything i'm just simply
visualizing okay so first one is the um
the heat map for tf idf
uh where i'm just looking at the tfidf
embedding
for the book problem
the book title problem so again you can
see there
obviously you can see that bits are
lighting up where there's similarity in
the bits where it's really dark means
that it's not
similar
the next one is um heat map where i'm
using sif
by the way
this one i showed you earlier is tfidf
and i said earlier that tfidf is
probably the least
performing out of the five okay so
please
yeah just don't forget that
this is the sif one which is a word
embedding
variant and again same problem so uh so
we've applied
um
sif on the same problem and we've just
plotted out the
the heat map
and then this is um again doing the same
but this time using a transformer model
and the universal sentence encoder and
there you can see actually it's
interesting to see that actually the um
usc
again if you compare that with this
roughly kind of looks the same but not
necessarily the same i haven't measured
anything here but just visually it kind
of looks the same
or at least there's some similarities
between the two
um profiles
and then finally this is where we're
using s bert
again on on the same data
and you know plotting the
the um
the heat map
any questions on this one
okay
right now
we've done a number of things
we started off by
um
trying to understand what is
sts sentiment
text similarity sorry sentiment textual
similarity
we looked at um
how to compute similarity
do we use jacquard do we use euclidean
do we use cosine
i then settled on cosine
then we then took the problem to another
place now we then said okay how do we
actually encode
text information how do we encode
textual information
we then looked at a number of options
five different ways to do this we looked
at
the very
kind of simple but very effective tf idf
we looked at
two two variant word embedding
approaches one is a very simple one
averaging the other one is the smooth
inverse frequency and then we looked at
um you know the google's universal
sentence encoder and then finally we
looked at the expert model
what i want to now show you is how do we
actually validate the performance of
these five
um you know and these five um models
that we've looked at yeah
so one way to do that is first of all
you're gonna have the right problem
to solve so i guess
in my case um i've
again just looked at what's been done in
the you know um in the in the domain
look at the research and um actually for
a number of years they ran this thing
called um
you know the sts benchmark problem where
a bunch of um academics in the field
experts will take these problems
well-known problems and they will
build models and then
essentially validate the models to see
if they are
performing to a level almost like kaggle
you know where they will have a lead
board and they will figure out
if if you know which model has got the
highest
metric
you know
in the ranking order so one problem i
looked at was this thing called this um
called the sentence pair problem yeah
the sentence pair problem and and what
that does is it's basically about 2 000
or thereabout
rows of data where they have two
sentences
so and the idea is to compare one
sentence against the other sentence and
then what's also cool here is that they
also provide you with a label so so
there's a label between i think it's
between zero and five a score yes um
it's a floating um a double or a float
yes so it's basically between zero and
five
and then what you can now do is you can
take your model and then you can you
know you can plug in your and you can
read each sentence and then compare the
similarities get the number that you get
and then compare your number against
their label number and see if your
number correlates with theirs
and you can see here that what they're
using here is not
accuracy
they're using correlation
because
their score is a value between zero and
five and that's kind of why in this for
this analysis
they've used um the person correlation
metric so what is the pearson
correlation metric let's look at that so
um person correlation metric allows you
to take
two vectors x and y and compare them and
see if they correlate with each other so
if the value is
one
it means there's full correlation
if the value is zero it means there's no
correlation yeah that's basically one
person and all it's doing is it it's
basically solving the
so the denominator is the covariance
matrix
of x and y
divided by the standard deviation of x
multiplied by standard deviation of y
and then so that gives you a nice metric
that allows you to compare a against b
any questions
okay so oh sorry yes
okay that's a good question it's a good
question actually
in the entire analysis
yes they do use
um
um
i think it's called sp um
yes that's right where they use that as
well i've just settled on um so they use
um pearson
as well as um
and this other variant of it i've just
used the pearson purely in the interest
of time
i had to get some numbers out but i
noticed that um if you again i mean if
you read the paper some of them tend to
use pearson quite a lot actually yes
however you're right
yes
it kind of makes assumptions about the
distribution
correct so this makes the assumption
that the distribution is um
i mean it's normally distributed correct
yes so part of this is that you assume
that the distribution that data is
normally distributed correct that's
right
i would say yes um
it approximates to normal distribution
correct yes
i mean in machine learning
we have to start with some some sort of
approximation of our distribution right
i mean generally we always start with a
normal distribution as the kind of the
as the hypothesis of our data but i i i
i mean i fully agree that you can use um
other metrics but if you read the
analysis
for the benchmark i used pearson was you
know what um you know what the
um the developers of
s bert for instance and even the
google's um
uh use
they both use pearson
i think google used pearson as well as
um
this other
um
correlation metric
not sure to answer your question does
answer your question
okay thank you
so
the next slide i'm going to show you now
is
essentially you know what were the
findings that i got when i used
the person correlation matrix as a way
to validate which one of these five
models performed
better
and that's the result there
so and so clearly expert kind of won
won the context
and then next was use and then of course
as expected sif
was third and then the averaging
technique was not as good as sif and
then of course rather bottom was tf idf
now i'm guessing that gentlemen i think
i think that your stats is very better
than my stats what i notice is that the
p value
which is a way to kind of
you know to reject or accept the null
test so so at the null test you know
using the um using the person um metric
is that
is is that is that the things are not
correlated well that's the knowledge but
actually here the p value was zero and
typically you you know you would check
to see if the you know the is basically
less than 0.05 but in this case it's
zero so i'm guessing it's indicating
that that there is some correlation
between the twos just that the
correlation
is kind of um
deviates from one technique to the other
and that the best technique seems to be
the expert
[Laughter]
probably yes yes yes yes correct
any other questions
okay
i think
we spent over an hour just me kind of
rambling and talking about stuff
i think the next bit now is i wanted to
just kind of walk you guys through the
demo the free demos and that hopefully
will crystallize some of the things i've
been discussing because then you can see
code and you know you can actually see
that this is not all waffle it's not
just theory you know it's also some code
i have
i've written some code that kind of spat
out some of the results so i think
that's the next thing i was going to do
but before that any questions before i
kind of get to that bit
okay cool
let me so before i go into the code
maybe i just kind of walk through each
demo one by one again so the first one i
mentioned earlier is the book title uh
um
problem and the idea is that you have a
basically a list of books titles
and the idea is
you select
you know one title and then you compare
this you compare that guy against the
rest of what's in the corpus and then
you see how close is that title to the
rest of the titles in the corpus
and it's very simple and then all i'm
doing there is i'm then splitting out i
mean i'm trying out different metrics to
measure
you know the you know this and the
similarity as i tried cosine euclidean
and
and jacquard so so let's start with that
one and again all of this stuff is on
git hopefully you guys have got the repo
uh unfortunately i think if you try and
run it you have to make sure you've got
the so it's got requirements.txt file so
you have to install all those libraries
now i i spoke to a gentleman earlier
today in hindsight i should have
probably created a container so that
it's all self-contained and i just give
it put it in the in git and then you
guys can just download it and then run
it on your machines and not have to
worry about all of the dependencies but
now you have to run the requirements.txt
so you can load all the dependent
libraries yeah but
i might probably go back and see if i
can simplify that maybe i'll put it into
collab and then just give you guys the
url of collab and then you can just run
it yourself in collab if you want to
explore any further yeah
okay so the first one i'm just going to
quickly
run the first guy
so that's this one here that's the
problem here
so um
actually before i do that let me just
show you the structure of the code
um so basically the code is
made up of this guy here problems so
inside this folder are the three
problems that i've um i'm trying to
solve so one of them is the book title
problem the other one is the the
querying
uh you know the very simple sort of toy
um
um sort of querying application that
just
um
what do you call it now um
basically you give a query and then it
goes and finds the closest documents to
that query yeah and then the third one
is the actual benchmark thing that i
showed you earlier yeah so i'm going to
start off with the
with the book title problem okay uh just
maybe just show you a bit more of the
infrastructure so so i've got a bunch of
um
modules in here that helps me
do things like nlp processing so i think
earlier oh sorry
oh oh is it okay all right how do i okay
now you got me
okay okay let me try let me see let me
see if i can do this so um
settings
uh
appearance
is it this one um
ah okay here so you want it to be this
guy here
like that wow
really really i've i've not used this in
ages okay yeah
is that better yeah okay all right cool
all right
all right sorry about that yeah okay all
right so um so i've got some basic
helper infrastructure
uh components like nlp pre-processing
so that lives in here that's just a a
class that provides me i think earlier i
think i talked about all these things
tokenization getting rid of lower casing
noise removal blah blah blah so that's
just a class here that just does all
that yeah just cleans up everything for
me yeah so again i'm not going to bore
you with all that detail but basically
just a cleaner um a bit of logic to do
that and
everything has got tests so it's got
unit tests to show you how to use it
okay then
most of the heavy lifting actually is
inside here this feature extraction
module and in here is where i've got all
of the different embedding
methods from the very basic tf idf to
the more
you know more complex or more
interesting expert yeah and then these
are all wrapper
it's a function that allows me to kind
of call those things um all within the
class so again i'll let you guys spend
your time and look at i mean i'm not
going to bore you with that but what i
will do is i'll try and run this now in
situ
um so i'll run each each problem one by
one so so the first one is going to be
this guy
okay and this guy is
in a class
uh so obviously these are all my imports
so these are all the standard imports
uh okay actually this should not be that
that's a mistake that's a unit test
which i'm not using here but i was using
before but basically everything else
are all the standard imports
and then down here all my own kind of
custom
modules that i've used
yeah some of them are helpers and then
uh i've also got login switched on here
yeah just a simple login and then this
is the
uh this is the constructor of the class
which will run the demo okay and then
inside there there's a bunch of uh
methods to do different things one to
initialize
so earlier i think i showed you the you
know the fact that i plot a scatter
i do a scatter plot and i also do a heat
map so all of that is driven by this um
initialized visualizer
okay and then i've got a bunch of um
things here just to run different use
cases yeah and i'll just run those i
think it's better if i just run them and
and then you see them in action so i
think i'm going to start off with the
um just computing the
the um the similarity metrics
so hopefully won't take too long let's
see
okay while that's going on in the
background i don't have any questions
from anybody
yeah yeah of course
yes
i'm not gonna answer that
[Laughter]
i'm not gonna okay
can i
defer
not answer that question
i don't get into trouble there so
although i said i'm i mean i work for
credit suisse i mean i mean that's my
day job but i mean
everything i've said here today is not
has no implications on credit suisse yes
i work as a data scientist i mean i need
a team a crisis but you know everything
i'm doing here this is my own kind of
indulge um you know this is my own sort
of personal thing and and yes i have i
did work on a project to do with cvs and
but yeah you know
[Laughter]
no comment on that one
[Laughter]
all right so um this is the results i
showed you earlier but here you can see
in you know institute so there you can
see all it's done is it's looked at um
so this is the query up here this is the
query just a single list
that's the query and then it's going to
query all of the
um is then going to apply that across
this
this collection of
titles yeah and all of that is inside um
this was pulled from the data that i
sourced online yes yeah and then all
it's doing here is just ranking
the
scores for each of the
different similarity metric
metrics yeah
so this you've seen already yeah so
again that's that demo please
in your spare time play with it
hack it break it whatever
yeah
so and that's the first one
any questions on that before i move on
to
the next one
okay
the next one i'm going to quickly look
at and i'm not going to have time to run
every single use case but earlier i
think i showed you
you know the scatter plot and the heat
map all of that is done with you know
with each of these guys here so i'm just
going to run maybe i'll run the um let
me see so i'm going to try and run
let me run the
the sift example so i'm just going to
again i'm not running all of them at the
same time because
i'm just going to run this guy here
hopefully this will take
so this is the word embedding example so
what this is doing is it's picking up
a glove a pre-trained glove embedding
and it's gonna then augment it by
applying this and this the sif thing i
talked about earlier the smooth inverse
frequency and then turn it into a
sentence embedding okay and then use
that to then do
you know to do this
so here again you've got
a bunch of queries so you've got one
column is the query doc
apologies and then other column is the
current dock and then it's just
measuring how close are they to each
other so obviously one means that these
two are the same
and then again
let's take another one so let's take a
case where it's not very close
so if you look at harry potter blah blah
blah there and then compare that with
this next guy here you see
that
slightly close but not very close up and
so again that's not 0.75 actually i mean
i should have rounded those to four
decimal places but i didn't do that yeah
yeah so again that's all that's doing
there is it's just taking so again
nothing really special in a way other
than that i'm using a um a different way
to embed the sentence and then i'm just
comparing similarities against each
other using cosine um you know
similarity yeah okay all right
ah ah sorry one more thing so and then
in the background it's
splitting out the heat map
so again that's the heat map for the
similarity matrix or the only the lower
triangle a little bit of the matrix yeah
and then also it's spitting out the
scatter plot
uh this is the uh this is mds so so it's
putting out the
scatter plot and then there you can see
and actually it's interesting so
if you look at the results you see that
so let's just take one example so if you
look at um
10 and 11 should be pretty much the same
so let's look at the result because here
is 10 and 11. there is 10 and 11. you
see 10 is on top of 11 there so now if
we look at the actual result
10 and 11 are one
so that's 10 in 11 so obviously that has
worked
so that's one yeah and again you can
spend your time and just look at it and
you can see that where is clustering the
the doc ids or the sentence ids together
where they're close would typically be
the ones which have
you know similarities
close to one
yep okay
any questions on that one
okay let me
in the interest of time
i will
move on to the second demo
okay so i'm going to move on to
okay i'm going to move on to the next
demo so the next demo is let me close
this guy
is the query problem
okay so this is a search engine problem
yes
so it's a very kind of rudimentary
search engine where i'm saying
here is a query a word or something or a
phrase
and i want you to search to find similar
documents
or sentences to this word yeah so again
i'm basically saying that here's my
query i'm going to embed it using any
one of those methods and then i'm going
to then compare that embedding with the
embedded
list of sentences and then measure how
similar
the query is to the rest of what's in
the and then rank the top 10 and see
yeah okay cool so that's the next one
we're going to do so for that one
i'm just going to run this guy i think
that yeah so so here the querydoc
document is
this this phrase computer program in and
um and here i'm using the classical
sorry sorry the classic um 20 news group
data sets i don't know if you guys know
about that um it's in psychic lens in
quite a few places it's a really good
data set it's basically um
20 different themes
um from from religion science space
whatever and
it's a very rich data set and it's been
used to typically um to
to
profile
um nlp you know solutions so i've used
it for doing clustering you know to kind
of prove that my clustering model works
really well
uh
and in this case i'm using it to
actually prove that my embedding is
working properly so i'm going to run
that right now and then
so hopefully this will be quick
most of the time is spent in loading the
um the language models
so
in this case it will be trying to load
the um
you know the
um hogging face hogging faces language
model which is what
the um expert is using so that's and
it's quite a big data set yeah
okay and it's now done this is finished
and let's see what the outcome is so
here
uh okay it's very long okay this was a
bit tricky because the data is almost
it's actually more than it's not just
the sentences are quite big they're huge
sentences and some of them are actually
paragraphs actually so what i've had to
do is originally i was going to display
the
the original sentence but i i suddenly
realized it's going to be very hard to
display that in a table like this so
what i did was i uh i had to apply the
cleaning function on it first so that
got rid of all the unnecessary things we
don't need in the sentence and then that
allowed me to manage it this way which
is probably why you can see here that
that the sentences are not totally
grammatically correct because it
stripped out some words already yeah
however the semantics still remains yeah
it's still there so you can see the idea
is that in here each of these sentences
it has some affiliation with the query
remembering that the query was about
computer science so let's go back to the
query so right here was a query computer
programming algorithm so now in here is
there anything in here that relates to
you know computer programming and if you
look at it carefully
let's look at this one here so that's
okay let's see
so these are all technical terms
so semantically there are some terms in
here which relate to computing yeah you
can see that algorithm
um
let's see
so again algorithm there um
yeah systems pointers
yeah
yeah um
it turns out that i selected this query
randomly
and obviously it's not as close so which
is why the top
score is not 0.66 but you can see i mean
again if you spend some time if you look
at the
look at the
the top 10 that it's recommended or that
it's um
and it's
yeah kind of decided close to the query
they all kind of have some some
affiliation with you know with computing
yeah so you know it's another way to
kind of build a very simple search
engine yeah if you wanna yeah
okay that's the
second demo
uh
i want to say any questions but i don't
think we've got that much time so i'm
just going to go on to the last demo
and that's this one so this is the demo
where i'm now just
essentially just running the
the sts benchmark and i'm trying to
see which one out of the five techniques
uh sorry how the five embedding
techniques has performed the most and
then i'm using the
um you know the person correlation
metric as a way to decide which one is
um the better one so again you've seen
that prior but this is just me running
it now in situ this will take
a couple of minutes only because i'm
running all the models together
especially the
the google's um universal sentence
encoder as well as experts yeah they
kind of have to read in the whole model
in memory
yeah
yes
sorry um
so what's the question again i don't
think i got it
yes
that's an interesting point um i've okay
i mean
generally you're right with with
transformer models generally you know
and they're advised that there's no need
for you to clean you know to do any
pre-processing so yes you're right so
and since those two are transformer
models perhaps in my case
i was running the same
corpus that was cleaned across yeah yeah
so these results relate to cleaned um
actually an sentences against correct
yes yes yeah true no no it's true it's
true you're right yes
okay ignore that error that's not my
error that's a tensorflow trust me
that's not my but um
it did spit out the results which is
done okay
and again those are the results so um on
that basis guys i mean um that kind of
completes my
you know my talk um i i really enjoyed
the session i mean i can't believe it's
an hour and a half
um it's been really really cool
and uh apologies if i'd rushed over
things i was trying to get a lot across
and um i will
the code is already on repo so please
have a chance to play with it and i
would try and see if i can push it onto
collab so you guys can just run it um
because cola would have all the
dependencies yeah
yeah i did in the stack
yeah yes let me okay um
yeah yeah
yeah sorry slack yeah yeah it's there
so so so guys thank you very much and
thank you
thank you
you